من اداره الاعمال تخصص جامعي الى قمره
القياده في قطار الحرمين السريع والذي
يحمل على متنه 417 راكبا تسافر روتيلا
نجار بالركاب والمعتمرين من مكه الى
المدينه مرورا بجده بعد ان اجتازت 220
ساعه من التدريب العملي وسجلت فصلا من
طموحها بعد ان بدات كبائعه لتذاكر في هذه
المحطه قبل ان تصبح ربه وهو حلمها الجديد
[موسيقى]
لما كنت اشوف قائدين القطار يعني مره كان
يشدن الموضوع انه كيف كانوا يتعاملوا مع
حجاج بيت الله الحرام والمعتمرين
فقدت ليش لا يعني يوم من الايام ما اكون
في نفس مكانهم ايش تس في فتره التدريب
العملي قرابه 220 ساعه لقياده القطار
تدربت من خلالها على انظمه الامن والسلامه
وكل ما يخص قمره القياده في القطار
وتدربنا ايضا على فرضيات مختلفه اا حتى
نختم الركاب بافضل وسينام ممكنه
[موسيقى]
رتيله ورنيم وغيرهما من الفتيات السعوديات
فتحت لهم الخطوط الحديديه المجال لقياده
القطارات للمره الاولى بعد ان تلقوا
التدريب والتاهيل عبر المعهد السعودي
التقني للخطوط الحديديه لمده 14 شهرا حيث
تلقوا تدريبات متقدمه في مختلف مهارات
قياده القطارات
417 راكب غير الطاقه من متواجد على الرحله
ففي خوف من
المسؤوليه لكن الحمد لله الرحله كانت سلسه
تماما في نفس الوقت كان في
رغبه في كده حماس اني اخذ هذه التجربه
لاول مره
جئنا ضمن الدفعه الاولى من قائدات قطار
الحرمين والذي انتهى بتخريج اثنتين
وثلاثين قائده قطار في خطوه الاولى
ينتظروا ان تتبعها خطوات اخرى لتمكين
الفتيات في قطاع النقل من جده سلطان
السلمي العربيه